這一波台股反彈上來
沒人去的地方才是好的地方
對 沒錯
假如你是主力的話要不開哪台車呢
主力當然要開這種車
散戶持股45.7
車上都是人啦
哎呦
大戶下降
敞戶上升
高檔申報轉讓
有這三個消息大概就穩了
通常看到這種新聞
又是高檔閉著眼睛空
那時候40塊後來掉到剩9塊
股票通常你要買那種沒有量的時候
沒量沒辦法出貨
一漲上來
有盤子來了
小哥好久好久没有见到你
对啊 两个礼拜了
至少两个礼拜了
一日不见如隔山丘
对 但是我一定要先问
算算好几年了
哇 小哥现在怎么样
想要来撩我耶
那个前几天
家里的老婆大人看了片子之后
他认真的看了一到七集
是
他就跟我說
下次你再被趙華撩
給他撩回去
是不是 嫂子開名啊
因為之前我撩小哥
小哥都說不要撩不要撩
不要撩
嫂子覺得這樣不行
下次不能來
對 下次要給他好看
是不是
小哥要給我一點顏色看看
顏色
對不對
顏色巧巧
等一下 我先考你
其中你考我
好
這些地方你有沒有去
沒有 都沒去
都沒有去
都沒去
這些地方你都沒去
對 我待會跟你講
我去哪裡
這地方我沒去
你都沒去
對 包含都不去的
我知道你有去兩個地方
什麼地方
你知道哪兩個地方嗎
一個是在我的心裡
一個在我的夢裡
是這樣子
你都來過了
好的
今天的理財達人秀
歌有仇必報單元
好高興
我好久沒有看到的小哥
來上節目囉
那今天我們很應景
我們兩個先彼此確認
去過哪些地方
為什麼
因為有些地方
你千萬不要去
這一波台股反彈上來
有些股你千萬不要碰
但是你知道嗎
有很多好的股票
現在沒人去
沒人去就是好的買點
所以今天小哥
會帶來一個非常棒的法寶
非常簡單的幾個步驟
幫你找到現在散戶還沒去
所以你應該去上車的好股票
所以沒人去的地方才是好地方
對 沒錯
怎麼讓證明呢
沒人去的地方可能風景很醜啊
給你看一下我去的地方
你看我去賞音耶
你去賞音 你好危險喔
去哪裡賞音啊
我在我的硬碟裡面賞音
硬碟裡面賞音好有遐想喔
低潮嘛
有人說那個人生低潮就要看低潮
看了低潮就會高興
所以裡面有一些女生名字可能有音是不是
櫻花妹
但是这个櫻花
这个蛮特别
真的
我去明古屋赏櫻
这四年前
四年前吓我一跳
想说你去
我现在马上就把你隔离起来
我现在也不晓得
几年后才能再去
因为日本疫情看起来蛮严重的
不过这个地方很奇怪
还真的没人
这一个人都没有
那这个櫻花
我到现场的时候
我也不是为了这个櫻花去的
但是开车在乡间小路
突然转个弯
看到这櫻花好漂亮
然後一下來看
這櫻花還有神社
這很美啊 這鳥居
還有一個小神社
大家不要以為小哥在推薦櫻花
沒有 沒有 不是 這真的櫻花
股票代表都有
這麼美
這個很美
我看了櫻花的牌子
我這牌子上面寫了1316年
你要推1316是不是
1316是什麼
也不是
好像要抬什麼畫
好 1316沒有
它是1316年出生的櫻花
所以真的是700年了
那时候我就想起了
席慕容写的一首诗
对 来 给你念一下
如何让你遇见我
在我最美丽的时刻
为了这个为你在佛前
求了500年
求祂让我们结一段成缘
对 佛于是把我化作一棵树
长在你必经的路旁
是不是
小哥像大树一样
順動的開滿的話
多了都是我前世的盼望
好 這喜慕容寫的
我看到這顆櫻花樹的時候
今年剛好700年
因為我四年前去的
2016年
看到這個牌子
這棵樹一定是我前世的成員
不是我
你看前世的女朋友
她就畫成一棵樹
躺在那邊等我
那金氏可以輪到我嗎
金氏要等來世
還要再等來世是不是
對 金氏不行
所以剛剛的賞鷹
是一個很棒的賞鷹地點
最近這幾年去日本賞鷹
由於日本開放陸客
對
所以最近賞鷹都變這樣
哇賽
一滑鼓子 你看這滿滿的人
你去市區賞鷹都長這樣了
賞鷹不應該這樣
所以小哥一開場就破題
就是賞鷹要到人少的地方
好不好 賞鷹到人多的地方
由於現在千萬不行
人多的地方會傳染很多的病毒
但是在股票市場上也是這樣嗎
小哥要來證實這一點
賞益跟股市一樣
對
人多的地方不要去
散戶集結的地方不要去
容易中毒
第二個高檔爆量是未來的隱憂
可是第一是我哪知道哪邊人多啊
人多你怎麼知道
然後第二高檔爆量
為什麼它不是大家很想搶著買
然後就衝上去
我們今天舉很多例子給你看
好
那我們來看人多跟人少
我們要看什麼東西
對 人多人少我們要怎麼界定
我們就看持股的分級
我嚇到
持有的股數 不要想太多
小哥現在100
以前400啊
小哥那裡很成功
你現在瘦得很成功
沒有 100就已經很過分了
400得了
好 那這個100跟400是這樣子
通常我們界定
這個持股100張以下的
我們叫散戶
持股100张还叫散户啊
如果我有一百张大力光
我才不会来上班
超大户 对不对
一般鉴定是这样
好 通则啦 因为那个是股王嘛
对 一般股票可能几十块而已
对 好 那400张以上的
我们就叫大户
对 那我们来看这张股票
这张股票最近飙翻了
这张股票叫金向电
对 金向电它散户持股
只有20.6%
对
大戶持股有74%
相當高
很強
只要這種比例我都可以買嗎
這種比例你要看它的位階
像現在跟你講
金像店你也不敢買
你變得它大戶這麼多
你也不敢買
你也知道
你起場點沒告訴我
對 沒錯
金像店這個太恐怖了
最近最標的股票就它
你知道為什麼你沒告訴我嗎
因為就是廉價
然後我們就沒有見面
對啊
廉價都關在家裡
對 沒機會
所以老婆把你關很嚴
就不敢跟趙华聯絡
我是這樣
被撩了
老伯說被撩不能臉紅
我沒有臉紅了
但衣服紅了啦
所以金箱店因為符合這樣的一個邏輯
所以標很兇
沒錯
但是小哥也要講
也要看它流動的一個趨勢
對不對 好
再來一檔
來看一檔
這檔是最近很難標的一檔
叫中石化
中石化的散入持股45.7%
快要一半
對 大戶持股38%
散戶比大戶還多
散戶愛用股
對 而且這樣股票還算便宜的
低價股 少要買那麼多
可能因為低價股吧
對 散戶喜歡買低價
對
車上都是人
所以忠實話最近就談不起來
翻車了 翻車了
對 談不起來
散戶他都會想說
那我團結一點
我團結一點
我只要買股票
一張不賣奇蹟自來
我必須說我要幫散戶說句話
趙華也散戶對不對
所以一張不賣的話
至少這波反彈
我的虧損就回來了
很多人是這樣想
但是剛好這波有反彈到
有可能這波是沒辦法彈那麼強的
然後趙華貴為散戶
我在8700左右的時候
我也是有衝下去買一些股票
對不對 也是有奇蹟
有奇蹟 奇蹟談到現在
現在賣了沒 還沒
還沒賣 對
所以你看到
我散戶怎麼可能賣
往上看到多少 武漢缺口
就是突破1萬2 站上1萬3
真的嗎
我在代表散戶說話
好 那我們等著看吧
好 看會不會突破武漢缺口
我是覺得有點困難
好 所以這散戶的心情對不對
散戶的心情
這是以前某個社團的標語真的 一張不賣奇蹟自來社團標語對 就鼓吹社團團員買這檔股票買完之後就說你們只要不賣奇蹟你就會看到了
這什麼樣一個宗教
挑戰大立光
這什麼宗教系統
對 很多財經社團
他們是走的是宗教的路線
他們看的不是籌碼 看的是信仰
看的是信仰 對
其實看我們理財達人
修多哥有熟必報
也有一半是看信仰
因為小哥就是神
我們是什麼叫
我們喔 哥懶叫
好 第二個
不是不爆石後未到
很多少買的股票在高檔震盪
很多人都以為是震盪之後往上漲
當然啊
那叫不是不爆
爆了之後就跌了
可是爆什麼呢 對不對
有很多東西要爆對不對
爆什麼
我們來看爆什麼
來
假如你是主力的話要不開哪台車呢
我是主力的話嗎
兩台車
兩台車是不是
小哥在哪台車我就上哪台車
小哥這個
小哥肯定這台車
對 想買的車
這個是特斯拉的跑車
特斯拉會不會開不久啊 不持久
這個聽說可以到1000公里
那可以 夠久
夠久了
這跑車0到100你知道多久嗎
0到100多久
0到1003秒鐘
只要1.9秒
1.9秒就到了
那太快了
還沒有感覺到就到了
這是另外的印度的火車
火車在這裡很多人看不到了
因為是佔滿人的
這個是他們火車有分三種票
坐票、站票、不用票
但是可以爬上去就對了
不用票長這樣
主力當然要開這種車
開這種車跑得快
才跑得快
所以等一下小哥就要告訴我們
哪一個是這種車對不對
對 好 我們再來看經典的案例
精彩科 很精彩喔
很精彩
在高檔震盪的時候
對
大戶急劇的減少
這邊有一個大戶持股比
對 大戶持股比400張以上
從45%跌到了40%
好 往下跑 可是才5%啊
他好棒
掉3%就很誇張了
掉3% 就很誇張了
好嚴格喔
這個掉了5%
大貨賣了3%
這個跟股票比起來差很多
好吧 所以3%
小哥覺得就是一個警訊
然後閃戶拼命的大買
不過這個增幅真的很大
增幅很大 這閃戶很誇張
大概從3 40%漲到65%
這就很誇張 對
閃戶都買進去了
你猜閃戶為什麼會買
閃戶為什麼會買
一定有好消息
然後一定有財報力多
消息力多 接單力多
很好 我們來看這個
消息是長怎麼樣
消息長這樣
他姓蕭明喜是嗎
就是我去查新聞
查當時的新聞
就查到金彩科前4月
EPS 2.19元
不錯啊
查完新聞之後
他們新聞都用老闆的圖像
超越去年全年
對 很多人看到這個
你記得股票是看未來
對
看到這個就跑去買
因為這個你看2.19就乘以3
就可以賺6塊
對 那錯了
後面還賺2塊而已
怎麼會這樣
我也賺很少
不過因為它是設備商
設備商有時候有路障的問題對不對
所以你假如看到高檔
你看到這新聞
這新聞人不要信
好
你要信的是什麼
哇
同一個人
這個坊間的新聞都這樣
一張照片一直用
就董事長不要介意
是因为只有这张
油田再处分5000张金彩科
所以这个叫申报转让
他的母公司就等于他的大股东
你只要看到这种新闻
又看到金彩科副总也同步声让
我觉得还不错的是
他的母公司大股东
要卖的时候有通知他们
副总听到之后也声让
然后看到这种新闻
又是高档闭着眼睛空了
那時候40塊後來掉到剩9塊
好 所以這種高檔
然後又申報轉讓
又放利多好消息
其實是很大很大的一個問號
對 你有很多個理由可以空它了
第一個大戶下降
第二個散戶上升
第三個高檔申報轉讓
有這三個消息大概就穩了
就差不多了
因為老闆都跑了
老闆都跑了你就可以來空了
對 老闆都已經打暗號了
對 打暗號了
通常這種我們都很喜歡空
但是像剛剛那些資訊
我們要怎麼樣去蒐集到
例如看到大戶下降了
散戶上升了
我要去哪邊找到這種資料
我今天有準備
對
台灣是全世界最幸福的地方
沒錯
對 全世界最容易買到口罩的地方
也是全世界最容易看籌碼的地方
也是全世界最容易買到電鍋的地方
最近大統很強
長不少不少
最近有官方認證
大家都去買大桶電鍋了
好 大物持股跟財物持股很早找
好的 這叫台灣集中保管結算所
集保所 你就打集保所
這裡有個資料查詢統計
集保股權分散表
你點進去 就會到我們剛剛的畫面
通通按照這個步驟到集保所
資料查詢統計
集保護的股權分散表
點進去
不過這查你看一看
會比較難看一點
怎麼說怎麼說
因為它沒有每個禮拜的圖形
讓你看
因為看圖形比較簡單
要自己一筆一筆統計
對
我們現在官方機構
比較有這樣的問題
對 沒錯
所以我們要呼籲
集保所或者是我們的證交所
為了方便我們廣大的股民
如果今天我們的資料
可以圖表化
絕對好不好
趙華今天就做一整集
來稱讚我們的主管機關們
好不好 呼籲一下
这个图形化比较好看
给你看一下最近一档
也蛮红的股票
这个是超佛星网站
它帮你图形化了对不对
对对对
这个网站叫神秘金字塔
神秘金字塔
它是免费的网站
它是我们的好朋友
好朋友
神秘金字塔
你们的网站很佛
现在要被灌爆了
要注意哦
因为他们上次
我们一讲他们就流量就
就爆了
然后就有点瘫痪掉这样子
好了
好
好 那這個你點進來
你就會看到這個
你可以選個股查詢
個股查詢
我查達爾夫
他就會告訴我
這個達爾夫他最近
這個大股東持有的這個
%數變成怎麼樣
好的 你可以看到
哇 %數大減
對啊 大股東大減
然後散戶又大增
對 然後他也有放利多
他放那個配息的利多
對 配10塊
散戶最喜歡配息了
對啊 散戶配息
可是我都跟散文講
你看到配息很好
你一定要再看一個東西
什麼東西
看它有沒有每年都配
對...
看它連續配幾年
所以我現在都有統計
配得很好
連續配20年
好公司
沒問題
只配一年那算了
今天配得好也不要參加
我參加完把它賣掉就好了
像達爾夫你連賣的機會都沒有
連賣的機會都沒有
所以配息要穩定配息
好 這個
這是神秘金的哪
對 很好
它有一個類股排行
股權類股排行用州來統計
這個資料它是每週改一次而已
所以你沒辦法每天看
每天看的數據都一樣
因為集保所它是每週公布一次
他就告訴我們說
最近大股東持有張數的增減
最近你就可以看到金像店
大股東總數就增加比較多
他真的很棒 他有上上
還有這種上完下的
它就让你看每个礼拜它的状况
这个镜像电我们看到
它大概都是往上往下往上
所以大部分接下来是往上
所以总增减13%
所以镜像电最近就很强了
所以也有往下的
或者是它已经下去又往上
这也是可以观察的
可以看出来
很棒 还图像化
所以蛮好用的
你看镜像电后面就喷出去
果然好强啊
很强啊
你可以看到总股东人数
它是越來越少
原本48000 後面剩42000
因為集中在大戶啊
所以人數一定會下滑的
然後平均這個每個人持有的張數
原本從11張變成12.8張
上升了 對
因為大股東持有的多嘛 對
那散戶越來越少
那平均的張數就變多了
大於400張大股東持有的張數
從原本33萬張後面變40萬張
就變很多 全部都有數據可以查
對 都持有完
那就分出去了
我們再看大於400%大公這個張數增加7萬然後這個百分比從60%到74%如果14%小哥剛剛你有提到
就是如果大股東掉了3%
你就覺得是景緒
那增加也是一樣嗎
增加的話就是好的
如果增加3%你就可以接受了
所以3%就是一個買進的訊號了
還是我只要1%就可以了
3%
還是要3%
所以跌也3% 漲也3%
好
那大股東金像電就符合這種模式
所以它最近最強的股票
好 那我要等一下
你要告訴我等一下會最強的股票喔
待會我們會講幾檔
好 來看一下
所以大家看完喔
最近最強的股票告訴你理由了
等一下小哥還會告訴你
等一下之後會更強的股票
是不是大補貼 你看
大概看這個四年前
小哥你願意我撩你對不對
沒問題
小哥的工具耶
這工具叫籌碼黑線
小哥把工具都掏出來了
來來 這個也是很經典的股票
這都往上漲過程中主力賣
然後大戶持股比率一直下降
散戶持股比率一直上升
從原本 原本大概才20幾%而已
增加到6、70%
這超級誇張 超扯的耶
這超誇張 到底幹嘛那麼愛它啊
這種就是有社團推薦的
對 你剛剛有講到
一張不賣 奇蹟自來
對 走信仰路線的
不看籌碼 只走信仰
這種走信仰路線後面就容易崩盤
還滿可怕的
就是不是不報 死後味道
你看在高檔的時候
這邊有兩個點
這兩個點這裡有一個字叫
申報轉讓
在高檔的時候誰賣啊
林醫科技
所以這邊就把它勾下去
它就會秀出來了
這個林醫科技申報轉讓
通常申報轉讓它
當時不是最高點
對
因為它也要讓得掉嘛 對不對
後面都會比它還低
我們常看到這樣子
它開始賣還會繼續漲
還會繼續漲
然後到後面股價就告訴大股東說
你幹得好 幹得漂亮 賣得很美
因為出貨最好拉高
拉高貨才出得掉
沒錯
這個就是被散戶追上去的股票
所以這種
小哥的工具很好用
沒錯
再來看最近的案例
好 再來一個
來 最近案例來看盤雅
盤雅在高檔這邊有兩個點
這兩個點也是申報轉讓
誰呢
王先生
王先生一個賣1000張
一個賣133張
對 王先生
申報轉讓1000多張
這個主力一路賣
然後你看一下大戶持股比率
從70%掉到了67%
是 王先生是他們的家族
法人董事代表 王家
那順道早上我們特別要看轉讓方式
轉讓方式有分一般交易
還有呢 鎮宇 信託
鎮宇跟信託都OK
鎮宇跟信託就不用看了
可能就是給子女啦
或者就信託起來嘛
大家不要動這樣
對股價沒什麼影響
但是只要看到一般交易
那就很容易跌囉
好 又學到一招
一般交易就是把股票賣出來
對
賣出來賣1000多張
後面的股票就跌下來
好
好 所以這個申報轉讓的Mega
剛剛講如果它是信託
或是贈與別人的
好 那沒有什麼影響
一般交易就是到股票賣囉
所以申報轉讓一定要注意喔
對 看到一般交易
這個空軍就準備要起飛了
好 來看一下鏡像店
最近它的現行很強
你看到齒伺比率就一路的上升
散戶就下降
這是很強的
這個已經非常的證實了
但是我在等金像電2.0
金像電2.0 待會跟您講
散戶追逐的防疫股
最近防疫概念股很多的籌碼都藏在這
防疫概念股很多都這樣
散戶特別喜歡
對 之前的國光森
國光森在高檔的時候
你看一下主力賣
這好明顯喔
對啊 大戶出股比率
從這個大概5、60%跌到剩42%
我覺得最奇妙是這邊根本沒漲
大戶就開始已經在
就開始要出了
因為有小小一漲段
你看這邊都沒量沒辦法出
對
沒量沒辦法出貨
一漲上來
就是有盤子來了
對 有盤子來了
有盤子來了
買盤雅的盤子
好 國光生
國光生這個
你看這邊量很多
所以大貨人就比較好出貨
所以有量就像賞英華一樣
很多人不要去
股票很大量不要買
股票通常你要買那種沒有量的時候
沒有量的股票是個好買點
可是如果在下跌
我們說爆量下跌
爆量下沙
不准撿嗎
爆量長黑下沙可以去撿
那個是去賺一根紅K
就搶反彈的
也是要跑
對
是這樣子
好 那你看閃戶15比1
就一路上升
對
國光升
閃戶為什麼這麼勇敢
因為大家想說
國光升會有疫苗產
會生產出疫苗
所以這真的很重要
如果看到大股東在往下跑
真的真的
對
大股東一定比我們清楚很多
沒錯
好
來
接下來介紹這一檔
我看到四個字
提前卡位
提前部署
提前部署是不是
超前部署
那這檔是
最近它的股價還躺在這裡
不是
它這個股價是發生什麼事啊
還沒講
還在睡覺是嗎
還在睡覺
反正想說它睡完之後會往上走
也睡太久了
結果沒有
睡完之後還往下走
對啊
因為疫情關係
因為睡醒了
發現全世界都在崩盤
都在崩盤
它也像這疊了
它這個貸寬
你還記得是貸寬嗎
記得
你知道貸寬只有幾%嗎 你猜
我只能硬猜囉
硬猜 隨便猜
7%
沒有 小一點
5%
再小一點
3%
3% 對
這張股票持有人 好無聊
這個腰太細了
每天上下3%而已
後面就崩了
後面崩了不是因為阻力到貨
沒有
它是因為怎麼樣
因為疫情關係
大家都在跌
全世界都在跌
所以它跟著跌下來
但是主力怎麼樣
一直買 沒意思買耶
主力還在買 而且買更多喔
而且大戶持股比率
比較低的從73%到75%
而且它在稅的時候
事實上它就已經在往上拉了
那散戶受不了了
什麼大股票一直跌
散戶一直下降 大戶一直上升
所以這種股票就是
大戶在卡位的股票
這種我也是
要是我散戶我也不太會碰
對啊 太無聊
因為鋼鐵股你就想
基礎建設好像現在也不怎麼樣
景氣又那麼差
我不懂它有什麼利多
可是大戶一定知道
我覺得最近看籌碼
鋼鐵股市一直有大戶在進來
哇塞 我以前有一個綽號
我以前跑過鋼鐵
跑了五年 對
真的喔 是不是
對 但是我不會告訴大家是哪五年的
就當作這五年吧
好的 好
再來看這個鷹業達
鷹業達 對
就是老公司了
之前在這邊也是在
這個貸款很小的時候
很細的地方
竹力也在買
對
後面因為疫情關係跌下來
對 殺下來
殺下來 竹力還在買
大戶增加 散戶減少
對
所以這種的反彈很值得搶
不過你不講我還沒注意到
它其實彈得很高
很高
對 它幾乎如果跟
到19塊已經創新高了
對 它如果跟1萬2000點
那樣的跌下來比的話
它反而還創新高
對 它是漲
或武漢缺口
好厲害
這就是因為它的主力在買
大戶在增加的關係
因為籌碼安定
籌碼安定股票就容易漲
最近這樣股票可能要小心一點
這股票今天也是大漲
未來觀察看看
它今天也是大漲
可是它最近主力有點在下降了
大戶持股比例有點下降
正在下降
從23% 4%已經跌到
剩下快16%而已
散戶慢慢的增加
所以这张股票
它去年最强的股票
那你为什么觉得未来观察看
因为看起来是比较不努力想
像这种大户在减
散户在增的
空军观察看看是不是
对 做多的你可能要找机会获利了结一下
因为这种股票筹码有点变差
好 这个要观察看看
这是给空军好的标的
或是手上有多单的人要注意的
那还要观察什么
來 接下來介紹這檔
這檔就很刺激啦
很刺激啦
喬春來 各位看一下它高點是94塊6年前六年前某個關鍵分點六年前的關鍵分點
現在還是它嗎
還是它
六年來都躲在那兒
這個我們去查
應該是老闆的分點
好
那這個六年前
這七年前它賣在這邊
這七年前賣
老闆七年前走過一趟
賣得很爽
這邊聲暴轉讓
賣得超爽的
然後各位你看後面
後面從90幾塊跌下來
老闆在30幾塊的時候大買一次
他90幾塊賣 30幾塊買
30幾塊買回來 3分之1價
那時候我們就 30幾塊買
我們要跟 對
結果跟了之後我就賠錢了
為什麼
因為後面跌到剩13塊
這個關鍵分點假的啦
這是肉腳對不對
他13塊又大買
繼續買 不是
那他就是口袋比别人深
这个有个高手讲
他说对大户来讲
这叫布局
那少说买在这边
比较这边的人叫凹单
那我是觉得说
看你投资股票的
这个想法是怎么样
不是如果老板这边卖这样啊
他钱可多了
这根本不算什么
没错
这个分点这六年来我算一算
他赔了三亿
就这个卖点我们不算的话
這六年來他買的
一直到昨天為止
賺起來賠3億
搞不好人家有300億在想辦法進場
今天一下拉長天
之後等他出的時候
他現在是賠3億
反正我們這節目都在
他出的時候
你看看他是賺起來賠錢
好喔
他出的時候我們就來做一集
對 他出的時候就做一集
你看看理財達就第八集的時候
跟你講這檔股票他賠3億
老闆賠3億
老闆會讓自己賠錢出場嗎
不可能
然後等他賺錢的時候
喬村老闆請客 請客
對 我們之後看看
我們之後觀察看看
因為我在他賠的時候
股價跌的時候
然後跟你講這老闆他持有很多
不過小哥你剛才我不敢念
我想說他是喬莊還喬村
還猶豫了一下
應該是叫喬村
對 喬村嘛
對 沒錯
好 這個來看一下
它大戶比率就滿漂亮的
慢慢的增加
現在已經到了67%左右了
最近散戶從26%已經跌到24%
真的降很多了
散戶凹不下去了
股價修正
所以我最喜歡挑這種
你也像鏡像店跟你講
你也不敢買
不是不敢買
是現在已經上去了
小哥你要起漲點跟我買
跟我講啊
我們要講大戶增加散戶減
然後股價在跌的
我庫存原本是賠險
今天變賺錢了
對啊 因為我也去超超跌
我看到老闆超 我也跟著超
你也太厲害了吧
你竟然會再13塊左右去
我本來也算長期投資
你也太誇張了 對
然後跌下來 帳面真的蠻難看的
而且它的量又小 不好出
最近跌下來 我看老闆超跟著超
不是 小哥 你三億幾塊買
你又不賣
那你不就是一張不賣奇蹟自來嗎
以後就有奇蹟喔
可能會有啦 我不知道啦
所以小哥在這些檔上淚散戶喔
但是用專業彌補
看之後會怎麼樣
之後才知道
最後呢
我們來看這個
剛剛講到的佩席
佩席
這檔它這個就很清楚啦
來看一下佩席配在哪邊
在這裡
很早就佩席了
台股它是佩席配得很早
佩席之前
有沒有看到這四個紅點
有
這四個紅點是生物爆轉讓
摩里希斯
你看這個一聽就是要避稅的大股東
他就躲在這個避稅天堂
賣股票
摩里希斯
他是500 500 500 1500 1500
還整數賣
3000張
分四個禮拜
等一下
可是你要告訴我
他轉讓的方式
巨額逐比交易
也是賣出來
也就是賣出來
好 那你看一下
這個它在高檔
為什麼這高檔
為什麼會有這高檔呢
各位你看一下這邊
這邊有一根 兩根 三根 四根
跳空漲停
這四根漲停
就是因為有佩喜的利落
但是我覺得好奇妙
那時候佩喜消息一出來
趙華根本不敢碰啊
因為覺得太奇怪了
太奇怪了 對
莫名其妙要發錢給你
拿庫存出來配
不是拿賺的錢喔
配完洗之後很多人講
沒關係嘛
反正我賺它的填洗行情就好
結果去買
買在這一天
配洗之後
就從來沒有填過洗
就一路下去
一路下跌
對
我們在這邊有空的
然後到這邊怎麼樣
要強制恢復
除洗要強制恢復
但他好聰明耶
空軍吃不到
在台灣做空軍沒有人權
都這樣
強制回補完之後
好不容易怎麼樣
好不容易已經可以開放空了
去空發現怎麼樣 都沒卷
被學員們都空完了
好不容易搶到了一張
搞不好卷都在大股東手上
我告訴你
那張我就很珍貴
一路報
你知道報賺了多少錢嗎
多少錢
30塊
哇 可是只有一張喔
對啊 佩喜的人想說要賺10塊
我們做空賺了30塊
而且還是半路進去的喔
最後我們要來唱歌了
唱歌 對
來看一下 這首歌我們就獻給
達爾夫高檔聲報的董事
還有參與除息的閃戶
這首歌很難
因為他的聲音
他的音域也很高
很高 對
說我們還是用念的好了
小哥唱 女生的我說真的
我去KTV點這時候我唱不上去
你唱不上去 我唱不上去
男生可以降Key啊 好
等等 你不是對他有意見嗎
有啊 有啊
你對他常有意見啊
沒有 沒有意見
真的 真的
人家有道歉就算了
不要這樣子
一開始可能沒有分清楚
口罩量不夠 沒意見
原曲到不了
你眼睛会笑
弯成一条桥
鼓励却是我
永远赚不到
感觉你很熬
在高档申报
除夕相鼓要
尽如此难熬
每分每秒
好 然后来唱一下吧
我找不到
我填不了
你所谓的
誓言的美好
我什么都不要
知不知道
若你懂我这一秒
我想看到
我在寻找
那所谓的天性的美好
我深深的靠谣
紧紧套牢
不敢卖掉
一时一毫
愿你看到
是不是你也不敢卖掉
因为你只有一张卷
我不敢補啦
不過除息的人不敢賣
因為賠太慘了
賠了30塊
好慘
所以這叫填不了
就是你要他的息
他要你的命
他要你的本
對
那是命了 已經不是本了
對 疊30塊變命了
好 是的
所以在這種時局很亂的時候
我們要注意囉
人多的地方你真的不要去
就是散戶聚集的地方
千萬不要去
所以小哥今天告訴我們
其實你用很多很簡單的網站
不管是官方的網站
官方網站我們呼籲
拜托拜托给我们图像画的资料好不好
或者是用小哥他爱用的工具
小哥的爱用的工具
筹码可以限
或者是说神秘金字塔
他都会告诉你大户的足迹
大户足迹只要他多买了3%
交根
多卖了3%
你可能就要考虑放空
所以今天这场课是不是非常实用呢
那这边赵华要加码一个好消息
因为你知道很多加入精英班的朋友
都说小哥怎么没有来
所以小哥就现在勉为其难地
跟赵华答应
小哥会来开直播
那直播的时候
请大家尽量来问问题好不好
那我们直播的时间会再通知给大家
大家尽量问
我们就会尽量地回答
那今天的理财答案秀
哥有仇必报就到这边了
我们拜拜
拜拜
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜